Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AI tạo một cái skill để lần sau
mình không cần phải trải qua những cuộc hội thoại và tốn token như
thế này nữa. Mình chỉ cần bảo nó là OK,
hãy tạo cho mình một bản PowerPoint với cái input là
nó sẽ tạo y theo mẫu này
Xin chào các bạn, hôm nay mình sẽ làm về AI skill.
Lần trước mình làm về PowerPoint, nhưng mình thấy AI của mình tạo PowerPoint
khá là xấu, nên hôm nay mình sẽ tạo một skill cho con AI
của mình để nó tạo PowerPoint theo mẫu của mình đưa cho.
Ok, let's do it. Đây là một bản kế hoạch,
kế hoạch PowerPoint mà mình đã tạo ra.
Thì bản kế hoạch này thì nó chỉ đề xuất là PowerPoint sẽ giống
như thế nào. Đây là tiêu đề, tiêu đề chính,
tiêu đề phụ, thông tin thêm, chia sẻ một số hình ảnh logo và
slide 2 sẽ trông như thế nào,
tổng quan về quan hệ đối tác rồi này kia,
và dấu mốc quan trọng với Việt Nam, đó. Đây là chỉ là một
cái bản kế hoạch PowerPoint gồm, 9 slide hay 10 slide,
và slide cuối cùng để cảm ơn. Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AI
của mình tạo theo một cái mẫu mà mình đã cho.
Đây mình đang có một cái mẫu để cho cái
bản PowerPoint này. Đây là mẫu mình tìm ở trên Canva.
Thì cái mẫu này đơn giản là Project Research của trường South
Fork University. Thì đó, thì nó có một số overview.
Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AI của mình tạo cái PowerPoint theo cái
mẫu này xem nó có làm được không nha. Ok,
bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AI của mình là từ bản kế hoạch
PowerPoint Hãy tạo một cái Tạm
một file powerpoint mới với mẫu này.
Ok, nó đã tạo thành công cho mình một file mới tên là New
Design để mình mở lên xem cái bản New Design này thế nào nha.
Theo các bạn thấy, nó không phân biệt được cái mẫu đấy là như
thế nào. Mình mở lên mà nó chỉ edit cái text vào PowerPoint thôi
chứ nó không biết mẫu là như thế nào. Tại vì nhiều lúc
AI nó cần khổng lồ. Nếu bạn chỉ provide mỗi
mẫu và input thôi, nhiều lúc nó sẽ không làm
được. Nên bây giờ mình đã có một file mới.
Mình đã có kết quả của file này rồi.
Bây giờ mình sẽ cho nó mở lên để cho nó hiểu
được output kết quả cuối cùng sẽ như thế nào.
Đây là mình sẽ bảo nó kết quả. Đây là mình muốn kết quả
như thế này. Thì nó lên làm theo kết quả như thế này thay
vì tạo mẫu text không. Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó tạo theo một
cái file mới dựa theo cái mẫu kia và kết quả như mình muốn
là trông như thế này để xem nó có làm được không nha.
Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó là hãy dựa trên cái ví dụ output
mà mình vừa chỉ dạy. Hãy dựa trên cái ví dụ output mà mình
vừa bảo để tạo lại một bản từ bản kế hoạch và bạn phải
tạo một file với hình mẫu là New Design.
OK con AI của mình đã tạo cho mình một bản mới.
Hãy mở bản mới xem nó trông như thế nào nha.
Đây, vào PowerPoint. Nó tên là
USA Vietnam New Designs.
Ok, để cho mình mở lên. Đó,
theo bạn thấy đây, bản mới của nó đẹp và hoàn thiện hơn rất
là nhiều, khá là giống với bản mà mình cho làm bản
mẫu. Đó,
tuy nó vẫn còn nhiều lỗi là lỗi chỉnh sửa lại,
thấy đây, có một số lỗi cần phải chỉnh sửa lại.
Các chữ nó đè lên nhau tại vì nó không hiểu được tất cả
mọi thứ, nó chỉ input file, input text vào đây thôi.
Nhưng tuy cái bản này cần chỉnh sửa nhiều nhưng AI đã làm công
việc khó nhất. Việc khó nhất của một công việc là bắt đầu công
việc đó. Mà mình đã có AI bắt đầu hộ rồi nên chỉnh sửa
sẽ dễ hơn rất là nhiều. OK.
Và mình muốn tạo một skill để mình lần tiếp theo mình sẽ không
phải làm tất cả những việc này nữa và bảo con AI phải hiểu
cái output này như thế nào rồi, provide tất cả những detail rồi mọi
thứ Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AI tạo một cái skill để lần
sau mình không cần phải trải qua những cuộc hội thoại và tốn token
như thế này nữa. Mình chỉ cần bảo nó là OK,
hãy tạo cho mình một bản PowerPoint với cái input là
nó sẽ tạo y theo mẫu này. Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó làm
như thế nha, xem nó có làm được không. Bây giờ
mình sẽ bảo nó là dựa trên cuộc đối thoại bên trên,
hãy tạo cho mình một prompt để từ sau mình chỉ cần yêu cầu
Input File Name Rồi bạn hãy dùng mẫu New Design và kết
quả giống như 2 cái mẫu mà mình vừa cho,
xem nó có làm được không nha. 2 cái mẫu kết quả giống như
Output là 1 này. Và kết quả giống như,
Với AI, khi bạn càng nhiều, càng Provide nhiều Input và Output thì kết
quả càng chính xác. Thế nên, bạn hãy Provide nhiều Input và Output Bây
giờ mình sẽ để nó tạo một cái prompt mới xem nó có làm
được không. OK. Ok,
con Gemini Pro 3.1 của mình đã tạo file mới
cho mình. Đây là file nó đã tạo là một cái prompt.
Để mình mở xem cái prompt này nói về cái gì nha. Đấy,
cái prompt này là tạo PowerPoint tự động từ bản thiết kế mẫu New
Design, Nice Design. Đây là nội dung của prompt đó và hướng
dẫn cách sử dụng của prompt. Bây giờ mình sẽ thử.
Bây giờ test được cái prompt này xem nó hoạt động như thế nào
nha. Bây giờ mình đã có một cái. Bây giờ mình có
một cái kế hoạch ờ, in PowerPoint của mình mình có một cái scrum
master guide của mình lần trước. Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó tạo một
cái ờ, bản PowerPoint từ cái scrum master guide này của mình
Xem có hoạt động được không. Tạo
prompt Tạo một PowerPoint
từ cái bản Scrum Master Guide này của mình xem nó có hoạt động được không.
Ok, nó đã tạo xong một bản PowerPoint cho mình để mình mở ra
xem cái bản Scrum Master Guide này,
PowerPoint này xem nó trông như thế nào nha. Ok,
PowerPoint, Spin, Scrum Master Guide.
Đó, bạn thấy không, bây giờ nó sẽ không còn một số lỗi như
trước nữa. Bây giờ nó đã follow đúng cái pattern mà mình muốn
dạy nó. Và nó khá là ok với mình,
mình cần sửa lại một tí nữa là được. Ok,
vậy đó là mình đã tạo một skill riêng cho mình để lần sau
nó sẽ tạo bản PowerPoint đẹp theo ý của mình và mình sẽ không
phải, ah, fix nó nữa. Đó,
nếu bạn có ý tưởng nào hay, hãy comment bên dưới.
Nếu thấy hay, hãy like, share, subscribe để mình có thêm động lực làm
những video tiếp theo. Thank you!